the example that i use is the ways in
which they have deputized a lot of these
local agencies right so the health
department has become an
arm of the government the osha has
become an arm of the government the
labor commissioner has become an arm of
the government
we have been served complaints after my
little spiel
from every single one of those agencies
that i just listed and when you go back
and you try and utilize the legal
process to get to the basis of those
complaints
you find out that they're all political
and that they are utilizing bureaucratic
red tape to try and take out those
people who even
mere question authority in california
i'm dave rubin and joining me today is a
restaurant
restaurateur
an entrepreneur the ceo and founder of
slap fish restaurant group
and a man with a seriously delicious
twitter feed
chef andrew gruel welcome to the reuben
report
it's great to be here thank you all
right first we just gotta
talk food pictures because i'm i'm
pretty proud as a regular
citizen a non-chef of the steaks and the
dinners that i put up on twitter
but if there is anyone that puts me to
shame
it's you you are just absolutely killing
it
on the food photos what is the secret
well first of all thank you because i do
drool over your photos i
actually go and search them you know
because traditionally
i've got to go find you now that twitter
doesn't want us to
get together right right right well we
are very dangerous people
posting food pictures with a political
bent you know
exactly i mean we touch the stomach
first and then
so look hey it's all about the sauce i
say this over and over again sauce is
boss
you all right so we're going to post a
bunch of your pictures as we're talking
we're just going to be laying in some
pictures so people are going to see your
lobster rolls and the cheese steaks and
the
and the steaks and just everything
you're doing is just awesome
and uh we are going to announce uh in
the next couple weeks we're going to do
a live
reuben report meetup at one of the slap
fish locations in oc pretty soon
how did you get into the food thing
before we get into why i really have you
here because you've been really
outspoken about lockdowns and what
has happened here in cali with newsome
and all of that kind of stuff but
what got you into cooking and all that
you know it's funny i actually went to
college for
piano performance and philosophy i went
to a small liberal arts college up and
you know i was just kind of a a drifter
right i i was there for a couple years
i was lobstering the whole time working
full-time in a restaurant
i started working in a restaurant
industry when i was like 13 or 14 right
so the bite happened
early you know and then there was that
inner kitchen culture
i call it like a band of pirates so i
could never get away from it and after
spending all my time in restaurants
while i was going to college i realized
wait a minute i got things on reverse
here
you know i'm learning about how to
protest capitalism on the one hand but
on the other side i'm uh
you know i'm really building my skill
level in the kitchen so i might as well
fulfill that path
did you want to be a chef first or more
of a restaurateur an owner
like what part of it really interested
you at the beginning
i mean it's always the food right so
like that's the exciting part that's
what drives me towards it is the food
ninety percent of being a restaurant
toward being a chef is really the human
element
we're psychologists we're counselors
it's about putting a schedule together
really big game of tetris but with
people's hearts and minds
i uh loved the food and
it was really the whole space so as i
got immersed in the restaurant
world i realized that the opportunities
were you know
limitless really from hospitality to
hotels to travel
et cetera so you know i mean i did
stints with the ritz carlton hotel
industries
got to travel and work all over the
place so it was it really was the
perfect vehicle through which i could
kind of
indulge in so many of these different
desires did you ever fear throughout the
adventure that the more
you grow the more restaurants you have
the more that you do tv stuff or
whatever it might be that that kind of
just removes you from
the kitchen part which is the fun part
yeah it definitely does and i've had to
turn down a ton of opportunities there's
been multiple cross
you know kind of crossroads if you will
where i've had to decide which path i
want to go down
whether i want to fulfill the vanity
element right and do a lot of tv and do
radio and media and all that and i've
always stuck to the kitchen
you know granted now here i am talking
with a celebrity like yourself but uh
i see that more as serendipity ah i'm
just a youtuber don't worry all right so
what put you on my radar was when the
lockdown started and suddenly after a
couple weeks people started fighting
back you know they're not letting us go
to
restaurants and i kept hearing from
people you know i'm in la which was
under severe lockdown
i kept hearing oh but you know oc is a
little better it's still
it's a little more conservative there a
little more red they're fighting back a
little bit more there's a little more
happening there
and that and then i was kind of trying
to find people that were there that's
when i came across you
uh well so first of how how many
restaurants do you actually have right
now and what has the last year
been like last year's been a roller
coaster i mean everybody's kind of
experiencing a similar thing in that
regards whether it's just you know small
business retail restaurant what have you
uh we've got
six slat fish locations in southern
california and i have two other concepts
i've got chicken concept i've got a
pizza concept
i did have actually a plant-based vegan
concept
that i had launched two years prior to
the pandemic that got wiped out in the
first month of the pandemic so
we really experienced measures and the
ways in which the government was or
wasn't helping
you know from the perspective of small
small business that was just my wife and
i
owner operator one employee um
and that was ripped out from underneath
us immediately we were trying to grow
that brand
so you know we've experienced everything
from i've got franchise locations around
the united states some do really well in
certain states like georgia and florida
um but then also we've got owner
operators that are franchisees in places
like albuquerque where the lockdowns
frankly i believe have actually even
been worse there than they have been in
california
that market's been crushed especially on
a hyper local level
and we've experienced that too so i've
had the opportunity and i wouldn't say
that the luxury i mean it's an
opportunity i wish i never had
to a dashboard that's got a lot of
different components what was going
through your mind those first couple
weeks you know you had the first two
weeks it seems like a lifetime ago but
two weeks to flatten the curve and
if i remember correctly everyone
basically obeyed no questions asked like
oh two weeks we'll do what we got to do
did you kind of feel that as as an owner
of a restaurant and then when did you
realize oh
maybe something ain't right here yeah
bingo exactly for the first two weeks
that's what everybody was thinking and i
and i joke about this and i say that's
when the cliche really was true we all
were in it together
and then we kind of put our business
capes on at that point because we
had let a lot of our employees go
unfortunately because we didn't know
what was going to happen
so we were almost encouraged by the
business community that yeah you know
you lay everybody off the government's
going to be really easy about making
sure that they get the unemployment
benefits and then you can just
or furlough them and then you can take
them back aboard so we tried to only lay
off those that were either
you know working from college living
with mom and dad
who kind of wanted the unemployment
benefits and then we kept on a lot of
our team members who were you know
sole providers for their family and we
pivoted immediately to be able to feed
all the first responders right police
emt
fire uh and then those on the met in the
medical field
and you know what was pretty funny about
that i joke i tell this little story
we were giving free food to anybody who
was a first responder
in these kind of broad categories and
you know
people picked up on that right away so
even within the first two weeks of the
lockdown
we had people showing up for takeout
they would go buy scrubs
for like a dollar to get their free
livestream so the grift was in from the
very
right so when when did you realize
though that like oh
this is this is way beyond two weeks and
we we got a much bigger problem here
well when everyone started to and over
intellectualized the numbers
right it was all about this you know it
it
kept getting higher and higher and
higher in regards to altitude right so
by altitude i mean
we're grounded in the beginning it's
very easy to understand two weeks
we flatten the curve we give the
hospitals opportunity to
increase you know all the necessary ppp
and the equipment they need in order to
deal with this pandemic
but then it goes into the next level
right in the stratosphere where it's
okay well now we have these metrics
about icu capacity
and then the numbers and we started to
play this overly intellectualized game
of math
where businesses couldn't even keep up
anymore uh so then
it was almost as if we were confounded
by the numbers
and just forced back into these
lockdowns
over and over and over can you talk
about just like the personal side of
when you had to make calls or meet
people or whatever it was when you had
to lay them off or furlough them because
i've met a lot of restaurateurs over the
last year more than i've ever met
in my entire life and most of the ones
at least that i've met here in la
they're not particularly political
people they they suddenly they've been
mugged by politics so now they're
political but most of them really were
just upset about having to lay off
people
you know people that had to lay off
chefs that have been working with them
for 30 years i met one guy who owned
something like 40 restaurants had to lay
off almost a thousand people
like and this is this is serious stuff
yeah and we're and we were at a point a
trajectory if you will in
in our business we had just kind of
finished recapitalizing the company so
we actually had just brought on some new
positions
from a corporate perspective and we were
trying to grow the franchise angle
and then it was an immediate sorry like
we just brought you on but we got to let
you go
and uh we let a lot of people go and my
wife and i it was just the two of us we
kept on a couple key players on the
corporate side
you know i stopped taking a salary it
was really about survival at that point
but the hardest thing was trying to
explain the people who didn't
necessarily understand what was going on
a significant portion
workforce they don't speak english that
well
many of them look frankly are uh
you know don't necessarily understand
the government framework in the united
states so it was okay you're letting me
go but am i going to get paid
i don't want to file for unemployment
because i'm kind of afraid of government
systems so
a lot of hand-holding my wife was
getting phone calls almost at every hour
of the day
trying to explain to people don't worry
we're going to be able to bring you back
on board we're going to loan you some
money we're going to help you out in
this regard we're here for you
and that was the hardest part how
stressful was it for you
financially i mean you're laying off
people to save some money but you had no
idea when things were going to open and
even now things are still weird yeah we
didn't have the cash flow to be able to
sit back comfortably and say we're going
to see this thing through we didn't you
know we have debt being called in
regards to all the different businesses
as i had mentioned with my my other
concept butter leaf
uh it was it was immediate right like i
still
had what was really fascinating about
this was i was still getting phone calls
from sales and use tax right the board
of equalization on sales tax saying okay
the year's up now you owe
x amount of dollars and i'm we're not
even open right we're in the middle of a
pandemic
they don't care i'm getting letters in
the mail that not only tack on the
amount that we owe and i'm talking
within the first month of the pandemic
but adding interest and penalties and
then more interest on the penalties that
never stops man
it's just crazy so were you did you
consider yourself
kind of political before this we we've
talked
off the record once or twice i have a
sense of what your politics are now i
can tell
obviously on twitter too but were you
political before any of this stuff
i've always been fascinated by politics
i was in model un youth and government
growing up in high school
i volunteered for multiple senators my
uh you know she was uh
she's an urban planner so you kind of
have to be across the board so it was
always imbued
in my environment but i was never really
really vocal about it and i always knew
not to be vocal about it
what was really interesting in the in
the in the restaurant space is that
i joke about how really chefs are all
libertarians you know you have anthony
bourdain who frankly i believe has
had some amazing uh we'll call them
quotes when it comes to the ways in
which government affects or doesn't
affect
the restaurant world and everything
beyond but everybody knows especially in
california just kind of keep your mouth
shut
and even in orange county right but
in the beginning of the pandemic was the
first time ever i opened my mouth on
social media and i remember
it was when we started to reopen and we
realized okay we can start to serve
through third party delivery
and we became a pillar in the community
and our sales started to pick up about
three weeks after the initial lockdown
so we reached out to a significant
amount of the people who we had
originally laid off
now remember i mentioned those were
people who were living at home college
students working with mom
you know kind of living with mom and dad
and
all of them i'm not being sarcastic when
i tell you this rejected the offer to
come back because they said i'm making
twelve hundred dollars or eleven hundred
dollars a week now on unemployment why
would i come back and work
and i get it right yeah we said okay i
understand i would love to be able to
make the same amount of money read some
books take care of the kids
um so i don't hold them you know
accountable for that decision but i
posted that
anecdote just on twitter and man
it went it blew up it went completely
viral
and i started getting attacked you know
along the lines of oh well if only you
paid your employees more then they
wouldn't be able to do that if you only
provided them health care et cetera et
cetera
and it immediately became a divisive
debate when all i was merely doing was
just saying hey this is what's happening
out there in the business world
right because even if you paid them
double that some of them might be like
ah it's still not worth it because i can
get half for free
and it's like there's no economics
behind it in essence
exactly well even a lot of the people
who are having come back
because we do pay a significant amount
of money for people to work in the
restaurant and then add tips into that
they were making about 35
an hour front of the house so let's say
they were bringing in 1500
a week but now they bring in a thousand
by virtue of the unemployment
they're still netting a thousand dollars
to not work
right so it's not a matter of it's not
an apples-to-apples comparison people
didn't care about that it was here's my
position
and here's what what's going to happen
so it just became at that point i
realized okay well
you know what i'm not going to sit back
anymore i'm going to dig in on this and
i'm
not i'm not going to be a dick about it
but i'm going to
use real life stories to kind of back up
some of these platitudes was that kind
of the first moment that you decided to
really get more vocal about all this
yup yup that was exactly it that was the
moment right there and it's funny
because if you go through and you do a
full
you know uh uh search which i'm sure
many people have done of my social
you will see that that was the moment in
time everything before that was
mayonnaise and fart jokes
that was when you put the red pill in
the
lobster roll apparently um what was it
like though so okay so then you get
confronted with that issue did you have
trouble getting guys back then because
of that
i mean did you have to hire new people
yeah yeah we did we had to hire new
people we had to completely
uh alter our operations so for me it's
i'm not always
i'm not going to sit back and cry and
complain it's okay well what can i do to
get ahead of this so once i realized
that one of the barriers was going to be
having accessibility to a strong labor
force
okay well then we're going to automate
our systems right so immediately it was
co-packing a lot of our sauces which we
previously made in-house
spices etc so trying to decrease the
units of labor that we need in order to
provide a high quality product without
of course compromising
what our original mission was as a
restaurant do you sense that some
restaurants
and i don't blame them actually because
it all just sucks but do you sense that
that many are starting to cut corners
and things and the reason i ask that
is you know you know because of my
twitter i mean we cook a lot around here
so i've only gone out to restaurants a
couple of times but i've noticed that a
bunch of the restaurants
stuff is just not as good and i kind of
don't blame them for a having to cut
corners
but also like the the zest for life that
a chef would have when they get to see
customers and get feedback and get
compliments
as opposed to just sort of being a robot
now on these takeout orders
bingo and you know i always joke i say
food
is representative of life um and by that
i mean
if you know if you're in a you know
everyone's partying and everything's
great et cetera et cetera it's like you
remember the flavors of the food you ate
in the midst of that right
the spice the pepper the acids the pop
this and that the hard char right just
this
overly amplified food and right now what
are we living through we're living
through a time where
absolutely everybody feels hopelessness
despair anxiety depression etc and i
think food is reflecting that so yes i
agree 100
with your point but i'm not just seeing
it in the restaurant space i'm also seen
in the hospitality space
i traveled a lot throughout the pandemic
and what i noticed was that people were
using the pandemic as a means by which
they could
increase profits cut corners but of
course blame the pandemic right so
no housekeeping no room service et
cetera et cetera you know old bars of
soap with hair in it
you name it we went i don't know if you
know the restaurant uh
boa in uh west hollywood or beverly
hills it's my favorite steak joint in la
we i took my team there last week for my
producer's birthday
i love that place the food is awesome
the atmosphere is great but this was the
first time indoors since this whole
thing
you know they had to do what they had to
do so it's separated you know the guys
have masks the waiters with masks and
face shields nobody's sitting at the bar
anymore they can't do the table side
caesar
and it was like we had a great time but
it just didn't
feel right to me it just kind of didn't
feel right
are you worried that as things continue
to open up that just getting the
atmosphere
back is is going to be tricky and also
people's ability to like want to sit at
a bar
and talk to somebody i miss that yeah
the fear is palpable and it's coming
through in the design the branding and
every single element of the restaurant
industry and that is
an in that is intentional in my opinion
right because what's happened is that
the consumer mindset and the business
mindset has been crushed with fear
throughout this pandemic
and the restaurant industry specifically
has been vilified
as these vectors have spread and that is
so wrong that's not the case at all from
the very beginning i said look we should
be used
as the proper models through which we
can you know
exhibit to everybody that you can
operate in a safe manner restaurants
inherently pre-pandemic are trained and
taught to focus on
safety sanitation serv-safe food handler
certificates
we're in some cases probably more
sanitary than certain
medical environments but yet we have
become
the fictitious villains of the pandemic
when none of the data and none of the
science proves that
and we've absorbed it right so now it's
these restaurant tours kind of
tip-toeing through and hoping that they
don't get canceled or that a private
facebook group doesn't take a photo of
somebody without a mask
you know it's it's it really is
unfortunate and it's going to put the
industry back
years what kind of crazy nonsense have
you had to do well i don't even know
where
so what's going on in oc right now are
you guys somewhat open indoors what
what's the regulation as we speak right
now yeah 50
indoors um we can dine outdoors now
which is huge
and uh you know obviously there's all
those kind of little levers that you
need to put in place in regards to
operations are still there
but people are scared i mean that's the
reality of the situation whether it's oc
whether it's l.a
um you know people kind of try and draw
the distinction between the two but it's
not as distinct as
as many would suggest um you know and of
course there's there's a political
tribalism that runs through a lot of it
and i tell people the stories it's funny
me personally
i have been the target of a lot of ire
here in orange county
and we from day one have been
really vocal about how we can follow the
rules but also open and operate properly
and that we are safe spaces for people
who want to get out but also feel
free and can eat um independent of fear
from covet
were you worried people don't yeah were
you worried that as you kind of spoke
out more against
lockdowns and some of this stuff that we
were talking about here that because
you're political you know because
everything sort of then becomes
political
that that was gonna have a cost
yeah of course of course um but it was
after i spoke out
uh against nuisance ban on outdoor
dining it was full panic right hitting
every single outlet from new york post
to what
what have you right this this this
little rant that i went on in my own
kitchen went completely viral
and my phone was blowing up with with
positive and negative comments you name
it
um but then what started to happen was
people started to support the business
from afar people were calling up saying
hey
i just run a thousand dollars on my
credit card i appreciate you speaking
out
and i realized at that moment that it
was true people had talked about this
idea that the people who cancel you are
not the people spending money at your
business
and it really rang true i mean look
since
we've been vocal and not i don't think
that we've been vocal in the sense of
offending anybody we've just been very
principled with our positions and
supporting those in the restaurant
industry our sales have been up 300 400
percent in certain certain circumstances
when that happened that shutdown or i
guess it was maybe the second shutdown
it's hard to remember the
order of all this but that outdoor ban
when when sheila cool
supervisor sheila cool here in la
announced she was the 3-2 deciding vote
to shut down outdoor dining
and then she went to eat outdoors in
santa monica to her favorite italian
restaurant
that to me was the one that like snapped
me i was at her house the next day
protesting because i was like this
like this is now beyond just beyond the
pal
yeah and you know i was getting messages
emails phone calls from
hundreds of restaurant owners in la and
orange county
all of whom are you know died in blue
democrats
yeah and and just absolutely livid
and it was at that point that i realized
that this is a non-partisan issue you
can make anything partisan
but really when we start to watch the
people who are setting the rules
breaking their own rules and then it's
literally crushing the businesses people
who put their blood sweat and tears into
it
now suddenly people's eyes open up so
from sheila cool going to a restaurant
let's talk
about our governor i know you're not a
fan of mr newsome
that's not even a question just talk
about him
look you know i i i i would love to be
able to sit down in a room with newsome
and try and understand what's driving a
lot of his decisions because he's very
very eloquent he's well spoken
sometimes he does seem principled we
know who's
driving a lot of his decisions he's
tribal with the ways in which he makes
decisions
he's a good team player for those that
are within his political sphere and i
give them that
but through the pandemic it went beyond
those partisan lines and he started to
do things
to fundamentally alter the ways in which
a lot of us in california operate and
look at local governments and state
governments and
i think that he was trying to set a new
baseline nationally
by out of his peers to say look at how
far i can go this is what we can do in
california
and look biden even echoed that message
when he said california
is really the example by which we should
all go the entire country
and a lot of that went to his head
clearly but when he started to break his
own rules
and this arrogant nature of his comments
about that
started to get you know replayed over
and over again on all these outlets and
then he would double down on it
it made me realize that his narcissism
was in full effect and i don't even know
if he was a human making those decisions
are some sort of aerobic
teen grand on booze alone at french
laundry that's a lot of booze
how much beer would i have to buy a
slapfish for 18 grand on taco tuesday
we're going two dollars so you know you
do the math divide by two carry the zero
that's that that's a lot of booze that's
a lot of booze
um all right so it came with some some
cost but obviously some benefit
i sense you're kind of actually digging
this this new direction just for you
personally
um it's tough right it's a juggle um but
i think it all still does come back to
food and that's what i've said from the
very beginning food is the great
connector
right it is the great unifier when it
comes to food
i mean you you know you can put all of
your
differences aside and argue over whether
it's pineapple on pizza or whether it's
you know toasting two sides of a grilled
cheese sandwich
people very quickly forget about the
reasons and we do need a little bit of
that unity right now and i'm not trying
to sing kumbaya
but i do feel that food is the vehicle
through which we can get there
yeah and part of the weirdness about
this was they kept telling us oh you
know just do takeout do take out and
don't go to the gym so now we're not
working out
we're you know most people if you think
take out although you can get all sorts
of stuff
it's like you think about chinese and
pizza and next thing you know we know
that the average person gains something
like eight pounds
in the midst of all of this while while
co-morbidities
include diabetes and and being
overweight yeah and one of the things
that i've said throughout
even pre-pandemic and throughout my
career in the food service industry
is it's all about personal right and
when they try and tell us how many
calories we have to put on the menu or
they try and
manipulate what ingredients can go into
our food i always remind local health
departments and those people advocating
for those regulations
that look this is about personal
responsibility
and if we try and this behemoth uh who's
telling who is making decisions for
people
and we lose that personal responsibility
then you know
that's a real dangerous and slippery
slope that we're on and i think that we
saw that
happen throughout the pandemic is that
we went from 10 miles per hour to 60
miles per hour
when it comes to fundamentally altering
the nature of our own personal response
so are you worried that at any given
moment
they could just pull more lockdowns i
mean as we're taping this we're holding
it for a couple days but we're taping
this on
april 15th that is two months to the day
of when gavin newsom says we can fully
open he is now telling us
june 15th there is no science behind
that
magically in two months we can open up
are you worried that okay so
so maybe they do it june 15th although i
remember august 1st remember
that was going to be one of the open ups
way back when but are you worried that
okay they could open us up and then two
days people go out next thing you know
on the 18th here we go again
oh and that will happen yeah i'm not
just worried about it i know it's going
to happen and it's actually
changing the way in which i operate as
an entrepreneur
uh look the pandemic has been the
predicate through which they have
decided they're going to change
the entire system right whether that's a
personal system or whether that's more
of kind of an institutional system we've
seen it
and i know that sounds like
sensationalism but it's the reality of
the situation
now that can be in one person's opinion
that can be changed for the good
in another person's opinion that can be
changed for the bad and perhaps your
middle of the road and you say oh some
changes have been good
some changes have been bad but
nonetheless it's been a massive change
and a fundamental shift
even we hear it today right now suddenly
they want to pack the court with
more supreme court justices right that
is a massive change to the very nature
of our entire constitutional republic
but those changes have set
a new precedent and we're seeing it
especially in the restaurant industry
and the example that i use is the ways
in which they have deputized a lot of
these local agencies right so the health
department has become an
arm of the government the osha has
become an arm of the government the
labor commissioner has become an arm of
the government
we have been served complaints after my
little spiel
from every single one of those agencies
that i just listed and when you go back
and you try and utilize the legal
process to get to the basis of those
complaints
you find out that they're all political
and that they are utilizing bureaucratic
red tape to try and take out those
people who even
mere question authority in california
and that is an incredible did you have
any uh actual one-on-one run-ins with
any of these regulators or health people
or anyone just showing up to your place
shutting you down anything like that oh
yeah oh yeah yeah
of course 100 and i've engaged with them
and spoken to them and what i think is
really interesting is they're people
just like the rest of us who want to
collect a paycheck and want to live
their lives um and when you start to
talk to them one-on-one to
really try and understand we had a
health inspector come into the
restaurant
three days after the incident up at
bravery brewing where the lady was
apparently dancing
yeah um but you know the the excuse was
no i was drying my hands
you know to the rhythm of um uh air
supply and
that's what the government should be
involved in figuring out if that's true
or not you know
yeah yeah of course of course exactly i
mean don't get me started on that
so so the guy comes in and i said hey
weren't you here a month ago
and he said yeah i said well i'm just
curious why why are you coming in again
he goes oh well you know it was just the
routine inspection and i said no that's
not the routine inspection and then he
immediately says back to me oh i saw
your post
about the health inspector up in la
right as if to kind of trip
i said what are your thoughts on that i
would love to have your opinion on that
um
and and he gave it to me and he said
well you know i think in la they've
gotten a little bit too stringent on x y
and z
et cetera and he kept it pretty vanilla
but the point being is
i saw that right that is incredibly odd
to me or coincidental
but you know that's just one little
example
um we have been we have been hit with
multiple osha complaints where customers
can just say oh they're not wearing
masks then osha will
give us this complaint and we'll have to
take the time and the opportunity cost
to lay out all the ways in which we are
actually following the rules
et cetera et cetera do you have any
evidence that anyone even got sick at
any of your restaurants at any point
throughout any of this
not only has nobody gotten sick at our
restaurant but we have actually kept
none of our employees have had
significant covet spread we've had maybe
three cases
and i a lot of my contemporaries have
told me about having to wipe out their
entire staff and shut down for good and
people ask me well why is that
what we as in within the free market we
have told
our employees if you even feel the
slightest bit of a sniffle
if you have a friend of a friend of a
friend who contacted somebody with kovid
take off do not come to work get a test
we'll pay for we'll pay for
all of your time time off all of it 100
if it's a month
it's a month we will pay for all of your
cova tests until you can come back
and what that's done done is that that's
allowed a safety system within our
restaurants whereby people feel
comfortable
taking the time off knowing they're
gonna get paid now have we had people
take advantage of that yeah we did
two or three people did we end up
getting rid of them for other reasons
anyway or they quit
of course you're always going to have
bad apples but guess what all of our
employees have been good
they've all been healthy we haven't had
spread within the restaurants because we
put that pretty mandated that we do that
can you talk about how tough it is just
forget covent for a second like in
normal times the good old days
just how tough it is to to start and
uh continue a successful restaurant
before all of this
nonsense well yeah the biggest issue in
the restaurant industry is is that you
have to have
people in order for it to survive you
cannot automate the restaurant industry
yeah you can put a kiosk up but you need
people to make the food you need people
to input the numbers
so for us it's been about managing
people
and increasingly over the past five to
ten years what we've seen
is just this crescendo of lawsuits
associated with the people elements so
it's become
incredibly risky to even endeavor into
the restaurant space and whether that's
third party lawsuits slip and fall
lawsuits internal lawsuits the lawsuits
associated with just general human
resources in states like
california new jersey new york what have
you um that the cost of even doing
business
is negligible you you you the only thing
that would motivate you to get into the
restaurant industry is passion you
almost get into it knowing you're gonna
lose money and if you break even you're
happy
yeah so speaking of break even you ended
up helping a whole bunch of people
financially
in the midst of all this too when
newsome shut down
outdoor dining the second time it was
right after the holidays
right after the every single news outlet
was littered with photos of people
shopping at black friday sales on top of
one another
indoors at walmart eating burger king
with their mask off or eating a hot dog
at costco with their mask off
in the takeout area i mean it was like
co-ed naked twister
and outdoor dining gets shut down that
was the only bastion of hope for
restaurant tours
in california and they were hiring a lot
going into the holidays so people were
feeling kind of good and then bam we're
going to crush the entirety of the
industry
the whole industry is shut down oh and
by the way california's unemployment
system
is in gridlock because we
misappropriated upwards of 50 to 60
billion dollars to
destitutes poor guys street dwellers
gutter snipes who knows where who knows
what
right we completely left people
on the streets and by we i mean the
collective we of the state of california
and newsom said
if we can save one life no you know
there was no message of hope there
right that's where i get frustrated with
newsome so what started to happen with
us
is that we were kind of known in our own
local community as an outlet through
which
people could get help if they needed it
and people started reaching out saying
i can't pay rent i can't pay like filed
for unemployment or i'm afraid to file
for unemployment if perhaps maybe they
were one of the undocumented workers
let's be honest right
and i can't buy any christmas gifts from
my kids as i said
so we said okay well look we've got
people calling up talking about writing
these thousand dollar checks we don't
want to grift for ourselves we'll get by
on our own but why don't we try and
utilize
and galvanize some of the attention that
we're getting raise funds for
all of those restaurant workers that are
struggling right now whether it's a
hundred the gap for rent or whether it's
500
to put food and gifts um you know under
the tree or on the table for the kids
and and you did it and do you know how
many people you helped or how much you
raised
or it was like a whole bunch of
different things that you were doing
yeah well we've raised over 400 thousand
dollars we've helped over a thousand
families
um we have you know my wife myself and
my kids i've got four kids
they were driving around with me
dropping checks off to people as far
north as the valley and as far south as
san diego
um it was funny this money starts to
come in first gofundme freezes the money
so we had kind of told people hey you're
approved you applied we looked at your
system all right we looked at all your
references you're good to go and then
there was no money so then we tried
coming out of pocket
wait did they tell did they tell you why
they were pausing it
or shutting you down or no it was like
it it was a glitch
yeah it was a glitch and we we were
frozen for about three weeks
so um that was really hard on us because
the donations kept coming in and we
wanted to help people it was in the
holidays time was very sensitive
so eventually it was okay well now how
do we get this money out right
you got limits on zell limits on venmo
limits on cash app all this so it became
we became
we were trying to run eight restaurants
in the midst of the holidays
while we were shut down well we didn't
shut down outdoor dining and then my
wife myself and my four kids with a
newborn were driving around southern
california
handing checks out to people or to
landlords because in many cases we're
paying people's rent et cetera
unbelievable absolutely unbelievable
speaking of your kids uh a lot of times
on twitter you're showing your kids are
doing stuff in the kitchen they're doing
some cooking they're actually they seem
to be learning life skills while
everyone else's kids are getting dumber
in the midst of all this i've got
i've got all the kids in the restaurant
every single day obviously the newborn
it's a little bit more difficult but
nowadays he gets it
but you know they're doing everything
from breaking down fish to
taking inventory counting the drawer
wiping the tables but most importantly
engaging with people right looking into
people's eyes
you know it's those those soft skills
we're teaching them those soft skills
and i get freely
now you really know that the labor board
is going to come after you they watch
this show like a hawk man
they've already fought they're already
unionizing the kids so
they're going to take on the man there
you go um what do you think is going to
happen
with newsom uh i think that obviously
the recall goes to ballot
but i i find it incredibly hard to
believe that
anybody who votes with a d next to their
name is going to vote for
somebody with a name when it comes to
actually choosing his replacement so i
think he survives the actual vote itself
i think it certainly is a [ __ ] in his
armor but um
you know the one thing i say about the
the democratic party is that man they
stick by each other's sides
um you know one resounding message
message one singular message so the way
in which they've all come out in support
of newson
with the same chorus the same refrain
the same narrative
has actually been look it's impressive
well i saw i mean that you remember
there was that like three-day span where
everybody from bernie elizabeth warren
every oh it's
far right wingers and right-wing maniacs
are driving the recall and it's like
come on it's not as you said before
these are not political people
no and i made the fatal flaw of tweeting
i disagree i i think i re-quoted like a
bernie sanders tweet and i said
this is disingenuous because my all of
my restaurant friends in california are
democrats and they all want new some out
well what do you think i became
immediately thereafter racist huh
ding ding ding ding ding wow i'm getting
good at this yeah next thing you know
you're racist because you defend
somebody for not being far right because
they want to go to work it's actually
quite
quite extraordinary speaking of the
recall though you know
you've got your libertarianish
conservatarianish beliefs
you're you're a functional human being
in a very unfunctional state
you're going to make a move here what
are we talking about yeah i don't know
if i'm going to on the recall
specifically and i did open my fat mouth
and i did say once on fox and friends i
said heck i'll run against newsome but
then i very quickly walk downstairs
after doing that skype
only to have my wife sitting at the
kitchen table saying we need to talk
uh but it's part of the problem because
because well first off you love what
you're doing it's very it's very obvious
like you love what you're doing why
would you want to be involved in that
headache and
and is that really what the problem is
rarity that every functional
good decent human being is probably
doing something a lot more rewarding
than just
micromanaging people's lives yeah
exactly and i but i will tell you this i
will run for office here in california
sooner rather than later
um and i will run on the platform that
chefs are the best
politicians because we understand the
ability to mitigate against waste
right and that would be the cornerstone
of my platform
that's pretty much all we got here in
cali so
so that's it all right to wrap this
thing up i want you to walk me through
so as i said we are going to do
a live reuben report locals meet up at
slapfish
in the next couple weeks i want you to
walk me through if i was hiring you if i
had the kind of cash it would take to
hire you for a full
day of eating walk me through three
meals
and maybe a little something between
lunch and dinner what's going on here
oh that's pretty intense well and let's
just put calories aside here and let's
say
you know calories aside calorie i sense
after seeing your pictures i'm gonna
have to put calories aside
everybody yearns for that over the top
ooey gooey egg breakfast sandwich so
we're gonna go with that breakfast
sandwich we're gonna go with a double
smoked thick cup
bacon um you know hard toast on the
bread i think
a nice hard crusty roll on the bread i
would be inclined to want to serve
taylor ham aka pork roll but the last
thing i want to do is create a schism in
new jersey and philadelphia
so we're going to go right to the bacon
uh and then you know for
a little bit of a snack thereafter i'm
going to teach you how to make yogurt
cheese and maybe we'll have some
fresh berries and yogurt cheese and then
we're going to go into lunch lunch is
going to be all about indulgent right
because you're going to work those
calories off
natural cut fries scratch made clam
chowder once again topped with double
smoked bacon and our
signature tiger sauce recipe uh should
be coming soon
uh you know lobster roll whole lobster
packed into a split top butter roll
finished with a little bit of brown
butter
maybe a touch of celery salt and then
you know going into dinner time we got
to do the reverse sear on
on a 48 ounce tomahawk i like to go with
the dry aged on that have to you can do
a nice wet age as long as you do that
hard salt ahead of time
draw out all of that moisture get that
salt in there a nice dry brine
and then for dessert uh we're just gonna
eat cheese and condiments
all right sounds good first off i'm
gonna make sure my guys are putting up
images of some of the stuff that you
were just talking about so people can
actually see it but wait talk to me
about the dry sear for a sec
sorry the reverse sear for a second are
you your full reverse sear guy basically
at this point
i'm full on a bigger cut of meat right
because the idea scientifically is is
that you want to keep your meat in
between 80 and 120 degrees for as long a
period of time as you can there's an
enzyme that exists that really breaks
down
and tenderizes the meat number one and
when you also reverse sear what you're
doing is is that
as it's cooking a lot of that moisture
is evaporating so when you sear at the
end
you get a much better browning on the
meat because look there's way too much
moisture in the beginning
nothing can brown in the presence of
steam so you know
utilize the time and temperature to get
rid of some of that moisture while
using the enzymes to break the meat down
sear it at the end get a better flavor
get a better crust get a better sear
and you get the best of both worlds all
right well this is what i want to do
we're going to do our thing at slapfish
and then i want you and the wife to come
over
and i'm going to reverse sear you a
steak and i want i want
full-on you know tv chef legit critique
i've seen your photos uh and uh i'm
excited so i actually am really excited
about that my question is who eats the
bone oh well the dog gets the bone for a
little bit
and then you know you're not they tell
you not to give the dog the bone for the
entire thing but
he works the well we're pretty good
about slicing david's an incredible
uh he's got some sick knives so we can
get pretty much everything off there
yeah i love the i love the slicing
skills so it's it's good to know there's
he's got the cleaver and the whole thing
well listen man i think you know it's so
interesting so many people
in this past year kind of kind of
crumbled under the way to this and you
can't blame them for it but some people
like kind of stepped into exactly what
they're supposed to be doing
and it seems like you're definitely one
of those people so i'm i'm
happy to be allied in this thing and
i'll see you soon in oc
and uh we'll link to all your stuff
right down below
awesome thank you i can't wait to be
hanging out with you
right on if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about politics instead of non-stop
yelling check out our politics playlist
and if you want to watch full interviews
on a variety of topics watch our full
episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell